[Musik]
Putins Rede zur Nation stehen wir vor
einer weiteren Eskalation im
ukrainekrieg Deutschlands Wirtschaft
weiter im Rückwärtsgang und immer mehr
schwere Vorwürfe gegen unsere
Verfassungsrichter die hätten in der
coronazeit versagt das wird spannend
heute mit
Energieexperte und SPD-Politiker Fritz
fahrenhold der ganz klar sagt die
deutsche Energiepolitik vertreibt die
Industrie und damit für uns allen der
Abstieg sein Präsident Joe Biden war
gestern überraschend in Kiew bei
selenski ein Besuch der ein klares
ausrufeszeichen setzte das sagt George
Weinberg von den Republicans of the
season Europa setzt euch mehr ein für
das transatlantische Bündnis
ein Staatsrechtler nach dem anderen
rechnet jetzt scharf mit dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht ab Professor
Volker ist heute hier und sagt unsere
Justiz hat in der coronazeit versagt
über das Versagen in der europäischen
Außenpolitik in den letzten Jahren
darüber sprechen wir mit
Politikwissenschaftler Josef Bramel er
meint die Europäer schlafen und die USA
die interessieren sich schon längst für
andere Regionen in der Welt ja das liegt
vielleicht auch daran wie Deutschland
Außenpolitik betreibt und welche
Schwerpunkte hier gesetzt werden das
ressour von Außenministerin Berber hat
jetzt seinen Entwurf zur feministischer
Außenpolitiker arbeitet in diesem zwölf
punkteprogramm ist auch die Arbeitsweise
im Auswärtigen Dienst geregelt dabei
geht es um mehr als nur um eine
gendergerechte Sprache es geht auch um
eine entsprechende Arbeitsweise der
Spiegel der zitiert aus dem Papier
folgendes die Botschafterin wird für das
Mainstreaming feministischer
Außenpolitik sorgen getragen also sprich
es geht um ein Geldtopf der soll dann
verteilt werden für Gender Gerechtigkeit
dass ein Thema jetzt bei viertel nach
acht Herr fahren heute eine Botschafter
in für feministische Außenpolitik ist
das etwas auf das sie schon immer
gewartet haben
halte das für so eine ähnliche
Schnaps Nummer wie
360 Grad Drehung die sie von Putin
verlangt hat oder wie die
Außenministerin Alleingang ja Russland
den Krieg erklärt hat und aus dem
Wahlkampf wissen wir ja auch schon was
mein Thema betrifft sie meinte ja die
Energiekrise mit der mit
tiefkühlhähnchen bekämpfen zu können die
man dann auf und abkühlen kann ich denke
wir haben ganz andere Probleme in
Deutschland also dass wir uns auf solche
irratischen
Politik peruierten
eindrehen müssen es kotzt einfach nur
ein bisschen mehr Geld ja mehr Geld aber
wer mal weiter rein gelesen was in
diesem Entwurf steht der Spiegel sagt da
drin steht feministische Außenpolitik
hält keine Zauberformel bereit mit der
sich unmittelbare sicherheitspolitische
Bedrohungen bewältigen lassen also diese
Einsicht steht da drin Herr Weinberg das
heißt feministische Außenpolitik wird
also weiter auch auf militärische Stärke
setzen setzen müssen beruhigt sie das
nein überhaupt nicht letzten Endes ich
sehe da keinen Unterschied zwischen den
sexes ich meine in der Politik zumindest
und es gibt jetzt gerade ein Film bei
der Berlinale habe ich vernommen wo
guldame hier als eben dort
von einer Schauspielerin dargestellt
wird es geht um den sechs Tage Krieg und
schon damals gab es in bestimmten Länder
Frauen die Politik gemacht haben und gut
gemacht haben und man kann nicht 50
Prozent der Bevölkerung irgendwie
benachteiligen
ausschließen aber jetzt kommt das aber
ich bin der Meinung dass nicht eben
gender entscheiden soll sondern die
Qualifikation und ich kenne also
viele Frauen im Business die sagen das
haben wir es nicht gerne wir wollen
irgendwie in den Vorstand oder in die in
die Geschäftsführung rein weil wir so
qualifiziert sind und nicht weil wir
eben hier ein eine Position ausfüllen
müssen Qualifikation soll entscheiden
aber sie waren auch bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz jetzt spürt man da
schon etwas von einem frischen
feministischen Wind ist Außenpolitik
vielleicht auch zu männlich geprägt gibt
es da einen Punkt den sie erkennen ja es
sind sehr viele Frauen anwesend allein
deswegen schon dieses eine berühmte Bild
mit den ja knapp 30 SEOs ohne Frau als
nicht mehr gegeben
aber mein Ende ist wichtig was dabei
rauskommt wenn jetzt durch feministische
Außenpolitik endlich mal nationale
Interessen benannt werden
Sicherheitsinteressen nicht nur
Deutschland sondern auch Europas dann
wäre das gut aber wir tun und schwer
damit wir können weder eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie vorlegen die ja
angeblich fertig hätte sein sollen in
München noch kriegen wir eine Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat hin also diese
Ministerien Kochen weiterhin ihr
Süppchen sei es jetzt masochistisch oder
feministisch oder was auch immer mir ist
es egal wie das Ganze betitelt wird es
sollte was dabei rauskommen dass dafür
sorgt dass wir weiter in den Sicherheit
und im Wohlstand leben können also das
Ganze mehr auf eine Sachebene wieder
runterholen bin mir Nessler gerade in
Behörden hat man manchmal das Gefühl
der Wind eine frische Ideen frische
Ansatz ganz gut tun das ist richtig wir
brauchen glaube ich frische Ansätze
überall aber ich glaube es ist das was
die Kollegen auch schon gesagt haben es
kommt auf die Inhalte an wir brauchen
was Frisches das muss aber auch effektiv
sein es muss vernünftig sein es muss
überlegt sein und einfach nur ein
frisches Etikett drauf kleben sozusagen
feministische Außenpolitik zum Beispiel
das reicht nicht wir brauchen eine gute
vernünftige Politik Außenpolitik und wie
wir die dann nennen ist im Endeffekt
egal wir müssen auf jeden Fall sprechen
hier in dieser Runde auch über die Rede
der Nation von der Vladimir Putin Herr
Weinberg war das in etwa die Rede die
sie auch erwartet hatten
also putin ist immer gut für eine
Überraschung das ist keine Frage und
ja das war eine hurra rede also für mich
war natürlich sehr interessant dass es
sein narrativ geändert hat weil
es hieß erstmal wir machen dieses
Special Operation und dachte in drei
Tagen ist er in Kiel und wird dort mit
den Fähnchen begrüßt und sein narrativer
erstmal er will die Ukraine von
Faschismus und Nationalismus befreien
und jetzt redet ihr plötzlich ganz ist
das mal ganz kurzig über den Kampf gegen
den Westen gegen Amerika gegen den die
verweichung des Westens der schlechten
attituts die wir im Westen haben großen
Teil natürlich auch im gegen Gender und
ähm
Homosexualität und alles solche Sachen
und
unterscheiden sich jetzt hier als der
große Moralist der alten Kultur
darstellen und ich fand dieser rede ich
habe hier die also bei CNN angeguckt
also mit dem originalübersetzungen in
Englisch und da waren natürlich viele
Punkte die mich sehr geärgert haben vor
allem null Interesse an einer Lösung an
eine wie an einem peace an einem
Verhandlung
hat nur hurra hurra und wir sind die
größten wir schaffen es und also hat es
gelogen im Sinne der alten Sowjets wie
das immer früher war und im Grunde
nichts Neues beigebracht und sie sagen
ja jetzt auch ganz klar da müssen wir
stark zusammenhalten da müssen wir stark
dagegen halten und das das klappt auch
nur mit einem starken vereinten Westen
und das ist ihr Thema heute ja absolut
natürlich und ich habe schon in der
frühen Sendung schon gesagt dass ich
auch für die Lieferung von den Panzern
war und
wir haben keine andere Wahl alles andere
ist in meinen Augen Naivität wissen Sie
wenn ich heute auf die Straße gehen
würde mit einem Formular und da würde
ein Kreuzchen sein wollen sie Frieden
oder wollen Sie weiter kriegen natürlich
wahrscheinlich zu 99,9% würde ich von
jedem Passanten ein Kreuzchen an der
linken Seite ging nicht auf der rechten
Seite aber das ist nicht das Thema ach
hier ist ein brutale Überfall von der
von der Russischen Föderation ein auf
ein Land das ist ein Bruch gegen die
un-karte und die Brutalität dieses
kriege es ist wirklich einmalig ähm die
Zerstörung der Infrastruktur der Versuch
die Leute auszuhungern
zu erfrieren und ihren Führungen die
Vergewaltigungen
habe ich nie gedacht dass das überhaupt
möglich ist und und wissen Sie was mich
natürlich stützig macht aus der
Geschichte ich meine auch der deutschen
Geschichte es ist nicht nur der Hitler
gewesen der diese Schweinerei
eingerichtet hat und Europa er hat auch
ganze Menge Helfer und da frage ich mich
wenn ich die ganzen Offiziere da sehe da
gab es so eine so eine Sendung wo er
dann vor den offizierern sein Mist der
erzählt und die hören alle zu und
letzten Endes das sind diejenigen die
auch vor Ort sind und die meines
Erachtens auch verantwortlich sind für
diese Verbrechen und die gehören alle
zum nach Haag oder wo auch immer und das
musst ja die müssen aufklären das muss
aufgefallen werden das nicht nur der
Putin sondern das sind auch seine Helfer
und ähm sie sagen also ganz klar da
braucht es als Antwort einen
geschlossenen einen starken Westen wir
sehen gleichzeitig auch immer wieder das
immer mehr Menschen fürchten kann es zu
einem Atomschlag kommen wie schätzen Sie
diese Gefahr ein also ich schätze die
Gefahr als gering weil
erstens es gab so eine Untersuchung und
ich glaube irgendwo habe ich gelesen von
CIA dass er seine ganzen Atom Dünger ist
in gar nicht so
bereit eingesetzt zu werden also da ist
auch viel
Korrosion und Mist aber abgesehen davon
wie soll das denn funktionieren diese
strategische Waffen wenn man die benutzt
man kann die nicht mehr kontrollieren
egal wo sie die einsetzen an ich sag's
mal in
Odessa oder in in Kiel oder wo auch
immer da gibt es Strahlungen und die
gehen danach Weißrussland nach Polen
oder war auch immer und da Leben
natürlich auch ganz mega Russen und das
jetzt in dornbird vor in der Nähe kommt
wie soll das abgesehen davon historisch
gesehen schauen Sie mal einen Vietnam
haben wir Amerikaner auch Atomwaffen
gehabt und wieder Vietnamkrieg
betroffen ist Wissen auch in Afghanistan
haben die Russen damals als sie
angegriffen haben auch Atomwaffen gab
also ich glaube nicht dass diese
Atomwaffen Waffen
benötigt werden er hat die Masse und mit
der Masse will den Krieg gewinnen und
letzten Endes geht es ihm um sein
eigenes Überleben verlierte den Krieg
ist er durch
also bislang ist die einzige Nation die
Atomwaffen eingesetzt hat glaube ich die
Vereinigten Staaten gewesen in deiner
Sack gehen Hiroshima es gibt schon eine
hohe Schwelle dazu das richtig aber es
kann natürlich extrem Situationen geben
also ich kann mir schon vorstellen einen
einen
übertreten von Truppen in russisches
Territorium das kann so irrationalen
Konsequenzen umgekehrt ich wüsste gerne
was passiert wenn man stelle sie vor
Russland
marschiert in Kiel ein was macht dann
was macht dann Amerika was macht dann
die Nato und deswegen das Thema dürfen
wir nicht müssen wir weiter hochhalten
dass wir
das sie die Führer der Welt wissen die
Menschen in der Welt wollen keinen
Atomkrieg
sie sind sehr bemesser ein Mann der
Justiz ein Mann auch der Fakten
natürlich das aber doch will ich sie
einmal ein bisschen emotional abholen
macht ihnen das Sorge macht ihnen diese
Entwicklung Angst
Angst nicht sorgen ja jeder Krieg oder
und vor allen Dingen auch ein Krieg so
in der Nähe der macht natürlich schon
Sorgen das ist ganz klar und es gibt
Atomwaffen ich möchte die ich teile
eigentlich ein bisschen die
optimistische Sichtweise von Herrn
Weinberg es ist tatsächlich glaube ich
so dass Atomwaffen wirklich so dass vor
allen Dingen in den abschreckungswoche
sind und dass man eben wenn man rational
denkt oder wenn man rational trainiert
wird man keine Atomwaffen einsetzen
können die Frage ist einfach wir oder
das Problem ist wir müssen Situationen
vermeiden in denen ihrer rational
gehandelt werden in den rote Linien
überschritten werden weil irgendjemand
vielleicht in der Ecke steht und gar
nichts anderes mehr will also wir müssen
so eine Situation vermeiden in der das
dann heißt nach mir die Sinnflut
sozusagen und das wäre dann eben auch
ein das wäre dann wieder die kluge aus
dem Politik von der wir vorhin
gesprochen
die kluge Außenpolitik der noch gibt es
jetzt am Wochenende eine große
Demonstration die ist ins Leben gerufen
worden von Alice Schwarzer von Sarah
Wagenknecht da waren wir da geht's vor
allem darum dass sie fest daran glauben
Verhandlungen könnten zu einem Frieden
führen kommt dieser Gedanke in allen
Überlegungen die wir hier auch in diesem
Tisch treffen auf zu kurz ich glaube
Verhandlungen sind dann erst interessant
wenn beide Seiten sowohl die Russen also
auch die Ukraine und die sie
unterstützenden Mächte zu der Erkenntnis
kommen dass jeder Zentimeter Land
gewinnen mit
unheimlich hohen Kosten verbunden ist
erst wenn sich das ganze Fest fährt dann
ist eine Chance für Verhandlungen da die
Geschichte lehrt uns dass wir da noch
vielleicht Zeit davon weg sind und jetzt
möchte ich vielleicht doch noch auf die
Waffen zurückkommen du kleiner Waffen
sind eher unwahrscheinlich ich glaube
das größere Problem für den Westen ist
die Durchhaltefähigkeit ich höre aus
Amerika Signale ja wir liefern Waffen
aber wir werden die nicht auf ewig und
drei Tage liefern können weil wir
nämlich hier nicht nur die Front gegen
Russland haben sondern auch China im
Blick nehmen müssen Taiwan und wir
dürfen uns hier nicht verkämpfen wir
müssen eben hier das Nötigste tun um
übrigens auch unseren Alliierten in
Asien zu signalisieren dass wir wieder
nicht so rausstolpern aus Afghanistan
oder rosarote Linien ziehen die wir da
nicht folgen also wir hatten vorher
Schwäche haben nicht genug abgeschreckt
haben ein Zeichen der Schwäche gesetzt
wie Europäer sowieso aber auch die
weltführungsmacht war alles andere als
stark so dass Putin eben unsere Schwäche
annehmen musste und jetzt muss Amerika
so viel tun als nötig um eben die
Alliierten die Nase und die geht
südkorea Japan Australien andere
weiterhin zu ermutigen Tribute zu zahlen
Handelsgeschäfte Dollar Dominanz und
vieles mehr aber nicht mehr man darf
Russland nicht zerstören sowieso unsere
feministische
Außenministerin vorhatte das glaube ich
wäre keine gute feministische
Außenpolitik dass wir auch nicht gute
Geopolitik wenn Russland nämlich
zerstört werden würde wäre hier in
Vakuum das China nutzen könnte also
Amerika tut nur so viel wie nötig um
Russland zu schwächen vielleicht um am
Ende des Tages vielleicht auch mit
Russland wieder einen Deal zu machen sie
kennen ja das bomo der Realisten in
Amerika hieß der beste
vielleicht nicht mehr mit Putin aber wir
haben sehr gesehen mit dem saudischen
Führer ja auch als ganz schlimmer Kerl
dargestellt wurde und beiden musste
einen Canossa gegangen nach ihr machen
damit die ein fast mehr aufmachen damit
wir hier die Ölpreise nicht in in den
Himmel schießen sehen also amerikanische
Außenpolitik war immer schon sehr
realpolitisch und wir müssen das
realpolitisch verstehen das hat mit
Feminismus wenig zu tun da sind wir auch
schon fast mittendrin in ihrem Thema sie
hatten gerade die Kosten angesprochen
dieses kriege es ist zum einen natürlich
tragisch die aber es sind auch die
Kosten der Wirtschaft heute eine neue
Studie die Weltwirtschaft hat 1,6
Billionen Dollar verloren durch diesen
Krieg endet dieser Krieg also erst wenn
wir jetzt mal ganz plakativ ausgedrückt
in uns nicht mehr leisten können ich
glaube das ist das kleinere Problem
dieser nach wie vor limitierte Krieg wir
gehen ja jetzt davon aus dass die
Erkenntnis die wir gezogen haben könnten
auch dann auf China erweitert wird wir
haben gesagt gegenseitige Abhängigkeit
das ist nicht kriegsfördernd man erkannt
hatte im Endeffekt Unrecht hat auch
keine behauptet wenn wir jetzt diese
gegenseitige Abhängigkeit diese
Interdependenzen wegnehmen es kriegt
vielleicht sogar noch wahrscheinlicher
also viele meinen jetzt weil wir mit
Russland blauäugig Waren müssen wir uns
von China rausziehen
ein Flächen der Globalisierung das ist
nicht nur brandgefährlich im Hinblick
auf einen neuen heißen Krieg vielleicht
sogar sondern es könnte ein Alter Krieg
werden bei dem wir diesmal nicht als
Sieger hervorgehen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass wir China von heute nicht
mit der Sowjetunion von damals
vergleichen dürfen ich glaube da haben
wir noch nicht wirklich strategisch
weiter gedacht was dieser doch
limitierte Krieg dann auch für massive
weltwirtschaftliche Verwerfungen haben
könnte bei denen vor allem wir hier in
Europa wir hier in Deutschland die wir
sehr abhängig sind vom internationalen
Handel die Leidtragenden sein können
jetzt natürlich schon den ganz ganz
großen Bogen auch mit der strategischen
Ausrichtung die ganze Welt und vor allem
auch Asien mit einzubeziehen ich will
einmal ganz nah an diesem Thema dran
bleiben es hat sich jemand zu Wort
gemeldet der meint eine ganz ganz
schnelle Lösung für diesen Krieg parat
zu haben und da schauen wir mal rein
gehen
[Musik]
also Donald Trump glaubt innerhalb von
24 Stunden wäre er in der Lage sofort
einen Deal herbeizuführen zwischen
selensky und Putin er sagt ich sag dem
einen Typen das dem anderen Typen das
und jetzt jetzt findet einen Deal Herr
Weinberg sie sind Republikaner trauen
sie Donald Trump dazu
Donald Trump hat ihn Vergangenheit viele
Sachen gesagt die sage ich mal nicht so
sehr
realistisch bezogen waren und
diplomatisch zu sein
aber
was er damit also meine ich jedenfalls
ausdrücken wollte dass er das war seine
seine direkte politikart dass er zu den
Entscheidungsträger immer direkt
gegangen ist und hat bestimmte Dinge aus
dem politisch auch erreicht zum Beispiel
eine Beziehung zwischen manchen
arabischen Ländern und Israel das hat er
direkt erreicht
er hat auch
sage ich mal einen gewissen Respekt beim
Pudding gehabt
und auch der chinesische Führer als er
in Amerika war da hat Trump den roten
Teppich da in malago in Florida
ausgeführt weil eben noch immer glaubt
wenn man zudem exekutiv
exactiv hingeht da kann man besser
direkte Sachen erreichen als wenn man
diplomatisch ob das jetzt schon mal
erwähnt durch irgendwelche Kanäle
versucht zu erreichen und
sie nicht alles was du dort haben in der
Vergangenheit auch gesagt hat muss man
wirklich nehmen das ist ein bisschen auf
eine andere Ebene bringen das klingt ja
fast wir fahren heute ein bisschen
sowieso ein Immobiliendeal in Manhattan
bringt in einer durch den anderen Deal
aber sie haben ein bisschen geschmunzelt
steckt da für sie ein bisschen Wahrheit
drin auch in dem was herein wird gerade
gesagt hat dass man
mit den direkt Beteiligten spricht also
ich sehe die Äußerung von Trump eher als
ein Zeichen dafür dass warum sagt Trump
das in Amerika doch weil offenbar auch
in den Vereinigten Staaten bei den
Menschen dort eine große Sehnsucht nach
Frieden besteht und nach
Friedensverhandlungen steht denn sonst
würde das nicht machen der ist ein viel
zu kluger Taktiker als er das sich nicht
vorher überlegt hat also wenn er wüsste
dass 90 % sozusagen lieber jetzt den
Durchmarsch nach Moskau haben wollten
dann hätte er das nicht gesagt und das
zeigt mir eben auch dass er
möglicherweise
eine eine
Tendenz in der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung wiedergibt die sagt wir
müssen jetzt auch wieder von Anfang
miteinander zu reden denn jeden Tag den
wir nicht miteinander reden sterben
tausende von jungen Männern und Frauen
natürlich und Menschen in der Ukraine
vor allem die Republikaner sind nicht
mehr bereit das zu machen die neuesten
Umfragen belegen die Demokraten ja aber
bei den Republikanern ihre Partei bricht
sehr vieles Weg sowohl in der
Bevölkerung als auch dann in Washington
schauen Sie Kevin McCarthy Speaker auf
der House er brauchte 15 Anläufe und nur
ja dank einiger Hilfe im Hintergrund ist
er dann doch über die Ziellinie gegangen
und der hat auch vorher versprechen
müssen dass es keine Blankoschecks mehr
für die Ukraine geben würde und der Deal
war nach dem 15 Wahlgang es hat vorher
nur noch vom Bürgerkrieg gegeben dass
einer so lange gebraucht hat ich will
jetzt keinen Bürgerkriegen vorauszusagen
obwohl das auch einige ihre Kollegen
machen auch Republikaner auf der ganzen
Ebene sondern der Punkt ist der der Deal
war das einer von diesen verrückten die
auch Trump neu stehen reicht um Kevin
mccasi dann haben wir wieder aus der
Hand zu nehmen das heißt wenn es dann
jetzt um die Schulden Obergrenze geht
und die Auseinandersetzung wird heftig
die Welt Finanzmärkte sind schon nervös
dann werden die Amerikaner sicher nicht
am eigenen ja sparen sondern sicherlich
dann auch den Europäern sagen Freunde
der Sonne ihr habt bisher zu wenig
Waffen geliefert wir könnten einen Deal
machen ihr bezahlt die Waffen die wir
den ukrainen liefern und wir regeln das
auch so dass ihr den Wiederaufbau zahlt
und ich glaube das ist absehbar da muss
man nicht viel von amerikanischer
Politik verstehen um zu sehen dass vor
allem die Republikaner die machte
Geldbörse nutzen werden um den
Präsidenten Bein hier die Hände zu
binden und die Europäer einspringen
müssen
weil das war typisch ich sag mal linke
deutsche narrativ was hier da gelegt
haben sprechen
also die Wahl von der Party war eine für
mich und für uns als Republikaner und
auch für die amerikanische
Öffentlichkeit Lehrstuhl in der
Demokratie
das war immer in den in den Reihen von
Demokratie geht oder nun also wenn sie
jetzt mich hier
unterbrechen nicht mit ihm diskutieren
also sorry
versuchen das jetzt noch mal eine
Antwort jetzt auch selber
ein Lehrstück viele Demokratie das heißt
man hat auch die Meinung der Minorität
in eine Partei Berücksichtigung wollen
und durchsetzen wollen das ist Nummer
eins Nummer zwei diese Untersuchungen
weiß nicht wo Sie gelesen haben auch die
Republikaner zumindestens 50% der
Amerikaner der Republikaner genauso wie
den Demokraten sind für die
Unterstützung von der Ukraine und
zweitens der einzige Unterschied
zwischen den Demokraten und den
Republikaner in dieser Hinsicht ist dass
die Republikaner sagen kein Blankoscheck
wir wollen wissen wo das Geld geht
wir glauben in die Demokratie neue
Demokratie in Ukraine aber wir wissen
auch um die Problematik der Produktion
und deswegen bitte schön das Geld was
wir von dem amerikanischen Steuerzahlen
zahlen hier die Checks vorstellen wir
möchten eine Kontrolle behalten also das
so wie sie das jetzt dargestellt haben
da habe ich absolut andere Meinung
vielleicht noch jetzt drauf dass das
jetzt kein Linker missverstanden ist
werden David Macintosh hier das waren
Abgeordneter den sie vielleicht noch
kennen im Abgeordnetenhaus in dem ich
übrigens auch mal gearbeitet habe
Republikaner der arbeitet jetzt für den
Kraftfahrer groß
und nicht die Partei bestimmt wie
Antritt als Senator als
Abgeordneter da gibt's dann noch andere
die dahinter stehen also wir müssen uns
von der Missverständnis verabschieden
das Parteien in Amerika wirklich eine
Rolle spielen es sind Klopfer gross es
sind Leute wie Leonard Leo der jetzt
wieder 1,65 Milliarden Geschenke
gekriegt hat wenn sie es nicht wahrhaben
wollen lesen Sie es nach in der New York
Times die Geld regnen lassen können die
dann bestimmen wer wo welche
Positionen sagen herzlichen Glückwunsch
und ich keine Haare
persönlich seit 20 Jahren also ich
brauche nicht genügend Personen ich habe
mich vorhin nicht ausreden zu dürfen
jetzt darf ich bitte den Gedanken
Weiterführen der vielleicht neu für sie
sein könnte also es sind sehr viele mit
sehr viel Geld im Hintergrund die
einfach nicht wollen dass dieser Trump
wieder kommt David Macintosh wird jetzt
alles tun um Trump zu verhindern er sich
aber nicht sichern da gibt's ja viele
Geldgeber die jetzt hier von Trump
Abstand nehmen aber keiner kann sich
sicher sein ob er nicht doch wieder
kommt ronde Sand ist soll aufgebaut
werden das entscheidet nicht die Partei
sondern das sind Leute im Hintergrund
mit sehr viel Geld sie vertreten und
zwar die Parteien im Ausland aber sie
vertreten eine schattenorganisation die
ist nicht in diesem Verständnis gibt wir
haben hier starke Parteien Sina Amerika
haben nicht Parteien wenn es eine Partei
gegeben hätte dann hätte diese Partei
Donnerstag verhindern in der Demokratie
entschuldigung das ist sehr schön dass
sie jetzt in USA oder unterstellen das
USA hat keine Demokratie
ich habe gesagt die Demokratie
von ihnen etwas nicht passt der
Präsident ist oder im Senat dann kommt
die Linke und sagt ja ihr habt doch gar
keine Dativ ich habe ihn
natürlich um die Demokratie
kennen Sie den Azoren wissen
Sie wer von euch Demokratie finde ich
mein Geld eingesetzt wird in Amerika das
ist doch eine Lehrstunde der Demokratie
ja
gesagt
ich würde gerne noch mal zum zum zum
grundsätzlichen Thema zurückkommen wir
haben ja über Trump gesprochen der
gesagt wir müssen reden ich bin kein
Trump Anhänger aber da hat er recht wir
müssen reden wir müssen sozusagen beides
machen wir können wir müssen kämpfen und
wir müssen reden beides also es geht
nicht es geht nicht dass wir sagen hey
wir kämpfen nur wir versuchen gar nicht
erst zu reden das wäre ein Problem und
das Umgekehrte geht auch nicht wenn wir
sagen ach naja wir hören jetzt auf zu
kämpfen wir ergeben uns und wir reden
nur das geht auch nicht wir müssen das
ist ja das was die die auch die
US-amerikanische Politik und die
europäische Politik in den letzten
während des Kalten Krieges auch geprägt
hat dass wir sagen wir haben beides wir
haben militärische Macht und
Verhandlungsbereitschaft und beides und
das ist letztlich das so habe ich Trump
verstanden dass er auch sagt naja wir
dürfen das Reden nicht vergessen da hat
er recht
vergessen wir das Reden derzeit zu sehr
naja jeder der
auf diese
Ebene der Verhandlung nur zusteuert wie
jetzt vor kurzem der französische
Staatspräsident wird ja europäisch und
weltweit gebäscht das ist ja im
Augenblick offenbar
nicht
gewollt das zeigt dass wir offenbar oder
zumindest System die die mediale
Mehrheit der Meinung ist
man könnte Siegen gegen uns das ist
glaube ich jetzt im Augenblick sonst
würde man ja verhandeln aber ich denke
ja ich stimme vollkommen zu
niemand hier in dieser Runde wird im
Zweifel ziehen dass es richtig ist
die Ukraine entstand zu setzen dem dem
Überfall Widerstand zu leisten aber wir
haben jetzt schon fast ein Jahr lang
vermissen lassen mal die Fühler
auszustrecken
um zu wissen wo sind denn wirklich diese
sieben Grenzen sie sind auch
sie sagen man muss ja richtig aufpassen
nur wenn man sagt man müsste verhandeln
ist man in der bestimmten Ecke drin
haben Sie das Gefühl dass man derzeit in
so einem Klima lebt dass wir in so einem
Klima leben dass man sagt ja ich möchte
erstmal feststellen ich bin natürlich
aber ich möchte gerne auch mal das sagen
ja ich kenne das ja aus meinem Metier
der der Klimadebatte nicht wenn man
sozusagen da etwas unabhängiges äußert
dann ist man gleich den klimaneutralier
ja ja
da komme ich gleich zu aber hier muss
man eben aufpassen dass man nicht gleich
abgestempelt für den anderen Tiefe ein
Putin Freund zu sein das ist deswegen
jede noch so neutrale Überlegung wie sie
sie da erstellt haben wird ja gleich in
eine eine Kiste gepackt und das ist
einen ein generelles nach der Nachteil
dass wir nicht mehr in der Lage sind
offene Debatten zu führen und bei der
Klima Debatte ist es genauso
was hat man zu verlieren was befürchten
sie denn wenn man offen ist
erlebt werden ausgegrenzt sie werden
nicht mehr zu Talkshows eingeladen hier
ist das Gott sei Dank nicht der Fall
aber ich war früher Stammgast bei den
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen aber seitdem ich
sozusagen mich vom Mainstream der der
Regierungspolitik
sie kritisiere
komme ich da nicht mehr vor die werden
wie gesagt meine Frau geostet ja sie
werden sozusagen als nicht mehr
existierende Person dargestellt nicht
das heißt sie würden jetzt nicht am
Wochenende fast Brandenburger Tor gehen
die große Demo das Friedens Manifest von
Sahra Wagenknecht haben allein in der
vergangenen Woche schon eine halbe
Million Menschen unterschrieben sie
würden aber sagen da gehe ich lieber
nicht hin
also ich habe mir das natürlich auch
überlegt und hat mir das angeguckt aber
ich habe genug eigene Baustellen als
dass ich mir sozusagen noch eine weitere
Bashing Baustelle an andere ich finde
es ist das gute Recht zu demonstrieren
aber man hat es offenbar verlernt das zu
akzeptieren das ist auch in Deutschland
Leute gibt die eine andere Meinung haben
ich will mich jetzt gar nicht äußern
dazu euch pro oder contra da bin aber
selbst die Diskussion darüber ist schon
vermiet und ich mer auch dass hier am
Tisch plötzlich alle ein bisschen
stiller geworden sind und nicken besteht
an diesem Punkt den wir hier gerade
gehört haben den Herr Fahrenholz
schildert so ein gewisser Konsens geht
es Ihnen auch so wir kommen gleich zu
ganz deutlichen Worten von ihnen
herabrabel da wollen wir noch mal ganz
tief in das Thema einsteigen zum
transatlantischen Bündnis aber haben Sie
das Gefühl man muss schon ich überdenke
noch mal setze gerade in Themen wo man
vielleicht leichter in eine Ecke
gedrückt wird empfinden viel dazugelernt
ich habe vor 30 über 30 Jahren gedient
und damals ja dieses wir hatten die
Stellung des richtiges Militär kommt
gemeint waren die Amerikaner die uns
geschützt haben die die Schutz macht
sind ich musste mir anhören dass er da
zeichnen Mörder von Leuten übrigens die
jetzt fordern dass wir ganz schwere
Waffen liefern die dafür gesorgt haben
dass die Bundeswehr eigentlich kein
Militär ist im eigentlichen Sinn also
entscheidend ist nicht das was wir
machen oder nicht machen da müssen wir
die Kirche im Dorf lassen und da bin ich
ganz Beine im Endeffekt wird Amerika
sein ob es Amerika den strategischen
Willen hat durchzuhalten oder nicht hier
in Europa oder uns diese Aufgabe
überlässt da können wir jetzt zweierlei
Meinung sein aber ich bin da eher
vorsichtiger sie haben weniger zu
verlieren sie können wieder nach Amerika
gehen wenn sie sich irgendwie wir müssen
weiterleben mit dem Fakt dass vielleicht
in Amerika Trump wieder kommt und der
mit Putin einen Deal macht der Trump der
seinen eigenen Geheimdiensten weniger
traut wir sind Helsing gesagt der als
einem FSB Mann Putin der kann wieder
kommen sie können mir keine Garantie
geben dass er nicht wieder kommt wenn
man das nüchtern ab wiegt und auch wenn
er nicht wiederkommt und der beiden wird
sich Amerika weiterhin noch Asien
abtreffen hier Asien zehn und das haben
sie jetzt sehr weil man kann gleich auch
darauf antworten ich glaube hier gibt's
auch gleich noch mal eine gute
Diskussion aber sie sind wirklich Thema
das ist nämlich die USA Link findet von
Europa und links Richtung Asien schauen
und sich auch da aber natürlich in
dieser Region neue geflickte Konflikte
auf tun kann ihr Thema und ihre Zeit ja
gut die Hinwendung noch Asien hat ja
nicht erst seit Trump begonnen
beiden damals noch viel zu Präsident hat
Obama sekundiert der sich von Europa ab
und nach Asien hingewendet hat sowohl
militärisch als auch
wirtschaftspolitisch was jetzt
Trump forciert hast ist diese
Konfrontation mit
China das hat beiden noch mal verschärft
Bein hat zwar einen konzilianteren Ton
mit uns mit unserer Europäern aber die
Verschärfung mit China dies real ich
glaube da können wir übereinstimmen
beiden macht vieles sogar noch härter
man könnte sogar sagen
Trump hat gebellt beiden beißt was China
angeht und das wird Europa noch vor sehr
viel größere Schwierigkeiten stellen als
dieses Scharmützel jetzt mit Russland
und Putin da schreiben
eines erinner mich würde aber vor allem
auch die europäische Rolle interessieren
und die Rolle Deutschlands ist
Deutschland nicht mehr interessant nicht
mehr wichtig aus ihren Augen nicht mehr
wichtig wir setzen
Politik geredet aber wollten eigentlich
nicht wirklich über Außenpolitik reden
ich erinnere mich an den
Wahlkampf Armin Laschet hat vergebens
versucht Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
ihnen jetzt nicht bei Bild sondern bei
denen die das moderiert haben
Außenpolitik näher zu bringen wollte
keiner drüber reden also erst nachdem
Putin angegriffen hat sind viele die
vorher von außen Politik nur geträumt
haben in einer anderen Welt aufgewacht
wir haben jetzt verstanden dass wir für
unsere Sicherheit auch was tun müssen
dass Militär auch wichtig ist dass
nukleare Abschreckung wichtig ist ich
glaube wir müssen uns die Frage stellen
warum hat Putin angegriffen warum hat
die Abschreckung versagt da müssen wir
selbstkritisch sagen ja wir hier in
Europa haben davon geträumt dass wir dem
Ende des äh ja der Geschichte
der ewigen Frieden dagegen war aber nur
nach Amerika muss selbstkritisch sagen
ja wir waren schwach wir haben mit
unserer Schwäche Putin eingeladen
sie können gerne reagieren aber ich
würde auch wirklich sehr amerikanische
Blick auf Deutschland interessieren also
hier waren einige Punkte angesprochen
geraten wir da ein bisschen in
Vergessenheit
ich nehme an weil sie scheinbar doch
orientiert sein sind sie kennen die
Hunter Geschichte FBI sie kennen die
ciao-geschichte mit beiden
mit der Mitte der ganzen narratives
gepresst hat
sie mich nicht aussprechen
bedeutet ich verstehe aus welche
Richtung sie andeuten ich habe nur
andere Richtung wenn sie mich
aussprechen lassen dann würde ich ihnen
das darstellen auch wenn Sie mich
versuchen natürlich aus dem Konzept zu
bringen es ist nun mal so dass die
Sicherheitsdienste CIA und so weiter und
so fort diese ganzen Geschichten mit
Putin als Putins Clowns den
ähm Trump über 200 Jahre dargestellt
habe und nichts aber nichts dahinter war
und so weiter also das war falsch ist so
viel zu den Sicherheitsdiensten und zum
Verfahren zu den amerikanischen
Sicherheit
und die dürfen nicht politisiert werden
FBI CIA NSA dürfen nicht politisiert
werden die haben einen Job zu machen und
das war's aber nicht politisiert damit
die auf auf Kandidaten oder auf die
Wahlen Einfluss nehmen das ist da gebe
ich Ihnen das ist eine Krankheit gewesen
in USA und das muss ausge das muss
sauber aufgearbeitet
in der These Deutschland hat zu wenig
getan als ich zu wenig nach vorne wartet
sich selber nicht ernst genug genommen
und setzt Außenpolitik nicht hoch genug
auf die Agenda sind sie sich vielleicht
auch in dem Punkt
nämlich das war doch der Trump der hat
gesagt er muss die zwei Prozent hier
aufführen sonst ist NATO ähm
das war der Trump der das gesagt und
jetzt plötzlich sind 100 Millionen zur
Verfügung und jetzt ist alles zu spät
und das Problem ist ein bisschen mehr
aus
wir haben schon ein bisschen was getan
aber ist zu spät sagen Sie also wir
haben nicht genug getan es muss nur
festhalten mit der Ukraine wissen sie es
wir reden hier über China und über den
anderen kritischen Bereich das kann man
mit Europa nicht vergleichen weil und
das kann ich Ihnen genau sagen warum
weil nämlich Japan und Taiwan und
Südkorea besser vorbereitet sind für
eine eventuelle Invasion der
kommunistischen China als Ukraine war
auch keine wir haben in Europa waren wir
total eingeloggt von dem Putin was für
netter Mann er ist und was alles so
erzählt hat und noch sieben Tage von dem
Angriff
obwohl beiden schon klar gesagt hat der
hat ihn vorher Nachrichten
Informationen dass diese dass das keine
Manöver ist weil sie da gezogen hat
sondern dass das Vorbereitung eines
Angriffs ist da hat man in Europa noch
gar nicht geglaubt dass das überhaupt
passiert und von da aus
natürlich Europa und da gebe ich Ihnen
auch insofern Recht muss auch hier die
Kräfte zusammensammeln und auch
verteidigungsfähig und willig sein vor
allem und
das ist alles eher auf dem Abstellgleis
landet das ist gleich unser großes Thema
hier nach einer ganz kurzen Pause das
hat natürlich auch was mit der
Energiekrise zu tun da schauen wir
gleich drauf bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig Realität fertig
ich finde diese Debatten unheimlich
wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und der Bruder sich optisch ein bisschen
angepasst
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand
das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Bericht
[Musik]
zurück bei viertel nach acht schön dass
Sie bei uns sind hier wird weiter
diskutiert ja die ganzen Energiepreise
die erholen sich gerade wieder puh
können wir aufatmen nein nein das
täuscht das sagen sie erfahren heute sie
sagen dass Schlimmste das steht uns erst
noch bevor auch mit Folgen für die
Industrie vielleicht sogar bis hin zu
einer Massenarbeitslosigkeit das ist ihr
Thema heute
tatsächlich sind die Strom und Gaspreise
gesunken und wir haben alle so den
Eindruck das war's jetzt aber wir müssen
feststellen Ursachen warte milde Winter
das waren natürlich auch die noch
weiterlaufende Kernkraftwerke auch die
Kohlekraftwerke wurden ja einige hinzu
geschaltet das hat alles zu Entspannung
beigetragen aber wir haben nach wie vor
noch doppelt so hohe Strompreise wie 21
und wir haben noch viermal so hohe
Strompreise wie unsere Wettbewerber USA
und China heute hat Deutschland weltweit
die höchsten Strompreise der Welt
hinter Burkina Faso Nummer 2
also die richtige Energiekrise kommt
noch steht uns bevor es wird bitter denn
erst gehen die Kernkraftwerke vom Netz
dann im nächsten Frühjahr die
ersatzkraftwerke mit Braunkohle und
Steinkohle und dann wird es ein böses
Erwachen geben der Bundeskanzler der
Bundesregierung hat gesagt ja wir bauen
jetzt demnächst fünf Windräder am Tag
und damit wird das Problem dann gelöst
es wird es nicht lösen wir wissen ja
Windkraftwerke liefern an 140 Tagen des
Jahres Nummer gerade eben
da null sind stehen sie liefern die
keinen Strom und dieses Problem will die
Bundesregierung lösen indem sie 40
Gaskraftwerke
Gaskraftwerke von dem wir ja nicht
letztes Jahr noch gehört haben wir haben
eine Gaskrise
zum Ersatz bauen und dann sagt man ja
dann machen wir am Wasserstoff man muss
wissen wir haben wieder elektrolyseure
wir haben nicht die Leitung es gibt
nicht nur mal wasserstoffturbinen und am
Ende wird das viermal so teuer und
deswegen was uns Kanzler Scholz nicht
sagt ist wir steuern in eine lang
anhaltende stromkrise und sie wird
Deutschland viele viele Arbeitsplätze
kosten dann gibt es die Lösung des
grünen Chefs der Bundesnetzagentur der
sagt na ja das nennt er last-management
aber was last Management heißt ich
stelle euch den Strom ab
Autos sollen abgestellt werden dann
sollen die Wärmepumpen abgestellt werden
die Strom intensive Industrie denn so
könnte man dann den Zusammenbruch
verhindern aber das ist
Entwicklungsland das ist
marc-entwicklung sondern sowas macht man
in Südafrika aber noch nicht in
Deutschland
meine Alternative die habe ich im diesen
Buch jetzt formuliert ist wir brauchen
Förderung des eigenen Erdgases wir
müssen nicht aus Amerika zu schlechten
Konditionen
Erdgas importieren wir haben es selber
unter unseren Füßen wir können auch
Kohlekraftwerke mit CO2 Abscheidung
machen unsere eigene Braunkohle nutzen
aber das CO2 rausholen und damit auch
China und Indien zeigen dass man sowas
umweltfreundlich machen kann und am Ende
es ist leider vergeblich lasst doch die
Kernkraftwerke so lange laufen wie wir
sie brauchen und das Sagen übrigens 70
Prozent der Deutschen
der Kanzler hat im Wahlkampf gesagt wir
wollen einen Strompreis von 4 Euro wir
haben jetzt 11 12 dreifache und wenn wir
das nicht hinkriegen und wenn er das
nicht hinkriegt wird die Strom in Strom
intensive Industrie in Deutschland keine
Zukunft haben keine Zukunft das klingt
nach dem ganz bitteren Urteil also
machen das einmal konkret wo sehen Sie
die deutsche Industrien wenn es jetzt so
weitergeht in zwei Jahren was bedeutet
das für die Arbeitsplätze die
Automobilindustrie die ist jetzt schon
am stöhnen viele Industrie in der
wandern ab und wollen woanders
produzieren planen das auch meinen Sie
uns einmal wir müssen uns alle stellen
das schreckliche das dunkle Szenario aus
wenn jetzt nichts passiert
wir reden über 5 Millionen Arbeitsplätze
die daran hängen und das sind ja
Wertschöpfungsketten das ist ja man kann
ja sagen okay müssen wir unbedingt
Aluminium in Deutschland machen aber
wenn man Aluminium weglässt dann haben
wir da auch den Aluminiumblock des
Motors weg und man hat beim man das
Kupfer nicht mehr macht auch die
Wicklung für den Elektromotoren nicht
mehr im Lande das heißt das Brechen die
ganzen Kaskaden der Entwicklung der der
Kette weg und deswegen ist das so
gefährlich das
überschätzt man häufig dass wenn man da
ein Stein aus der Mauer fällt zieht das
sind die gesamte Mauer zusammenfällt sie
können nicht einfach in einem Chemiewerk
sagen ach dann mache ich jetzt keinen
Ammoniak mehr oder ich mache jetzt nur
noch Kerosin das andere mache ich aber
nicht das funktioniert so nicht weil wir
sind eine Wirtschaft die so verzahnt ist
wo die wirklich
miteinander verknüpft ist da mache ich
mir wirklich große Sorgen und ich glaube
wir haben es noch in der Hand ähm
das zu lösen aber es gehören jetzt ein
paar Wahrheiten auf den Tisch und die
Wahrheit heißt wir müssen jetzt erstmal
das Angebot erweitern wir dürfen uns
nicht darauf verlassen auf Gas Importe
stehen sie vor was wir gemacht haben im
letzten Jahr wir haben
hochgejagt weil wir wollten ja nicht
wieder zurück in die Kohle und dann
haben wir Pakistan und Bangladesch und
anderen das Gas weggekauft was haben die
jetzt gemacht pakistan hat gesagt der
Gaspreis ist für uns jetzt so hoch durch
die Deutschen und unter anderem
hochgetrieben durch einen Weg wir bauen
jetzt nur noch Kohlekraftwerke die bauen
jetzt Kohlekraftwerk aus denen wir jetzt
aussteigen wollen mit eurem Erdgas ja
der Wirtschaftsminister war ein katata
wir brauchen nur für 5 Jahre dann wollen
wir alles in Wasserstoff Mann ist
natürlich totaler Blödsinn ich weiß
nicht wir haben das erzählt hat das ist
und Märchen von den Grünen dürfte sie
das ja nicht wundern da stand ja auch
ganz klar in der Programm da weiß man
aber wie überrascht sind sie von ihrer
eigenen SPD dass man da in der
Energiewende auch weiter fährt
fängt jetzt langsam an nicht die DGB
Vorsitzende sagt jetzt zum ersten Mal
ich war eine Form Zusammenbruch der
deutschen Industrie das ist ja schon mal
was aber liebe DGB Vorstandsvorsitzende
warnen reicht nicht es muss dann auch
guten Vorschlag herkommen und der ist
unangenehm ich weiß das wenn wir jetzt
sagen lass uns doch unser eigenes Erdgas
fördern wir können das übrigens viel
besser als die Amerikaner die Amerikaner
lassen nämlich die die Bohrlöcher offen
und dann geht das Erdgas hinterher noch
raus und das ist ja klimaschädlich
außerdem verlieren wir 25% beim
Transport das ist auch viel teurer aber
was will natürlich an Deutschland
deswegen keiner weil wir eine riesige
Angst davor haben wenn wir ein eine
erdgasbohrung in Niedersachsen
Sachsen-Anhalt wo wir wirklich für die
nächsten 20 30 Jahre eigenes preiswertes
Erdgas haben wenn wir das machen dann
wissen wir was passiert dann klebt sich
am nächsten Tag Ende Gelände da an den
bordturm und da wir sind nicht mehr in
der Lage das dann durchzusetzen das ist
das große Problem und es wird dann die
die Medien werden sagen ja man musste
auch verstehen und so das sind nein wir
müssen jetzt langsam begreifen dass wir
uns unser Schicksal selbst in die Hand
nehmen müssen und ich wünsche mir
dass der Kanzler sich mehr von
Ingenieuren und Energietechniker beraten
lässt und sich nicht irgendwelche Flöhe
ins Ohr setzen lässt von Frau lang oder
vom
spd-generalsekretär das das fehlt jetzt
oder von einem Kühnert und von
Frauenärztin die dann mit
Steuererhöhungen um das ganze zu finden
der Wirtschaft geht schlimm genug wir
haben durch die energiepreiskrise schon
mal einen Nachteil gegenüber unseren
Wettbewerbern in China und in den USA
und jetzt kommen noch Diskussion über
Steuererhöhung das ist Gift das ist gut
weg aus Deutschland für viele natürlich
das ist ja schon angefangen
investiert in China Daimler Benz hat die
Motoren Produktion nach China verlagert
und das schlimme ist das hilft dem Klima
überhaupt nicht wenn wir das hier kaputt
machen dort in China das zu produzieren
wird mit einem viel höheren CO2 Ausstoß
verbunden weil die ihre Energie eben zum
überwiegenden Teil aus Kohle machen dass
er besonders klim aber sie haben lange
einen USA gelebt wenn man das jetzt hört
wenn man auch sieht was mit unter
unserer Industrie passieren könne dann
lachen sie sich doch kaputt der ist doch
Deutschland mit seiner Wirtschaftskraft
immer unbedeutender und somit doch auch
immer weniger ernst zu nehmender
genommen deswegen wird die auch noch
Amerika gelockt die Schwäche die wir
jetzt haben ja wir müssen den Preis
zahlen jetzt dieses energiekrieges wird
nahtlos ausgenutzt nicht ich glaube
Trump wäre gar nicht so gut weil er eben
wenig fokussiert ist aber beiden macht
es jetzt mit dem sogenannten im Flaschen
reduction Act also hier funktioniert und
da haben sich schon viele anlocken
lassen irgendwann werden wir vielleicht
keine Energie Problem mehr haben weil
wir keine Industrie mehr haben die
Energie braucht wir haben teilweise
schon diese Effekte also da wird viel
abgeworben im Namen der Reduzierung der
Inflation aber das größere Problem
glaube ich das nicht nur uns sondern
auch Amerika und damit auch die ganze
Welt betrifft ist dass wir auf einem ja
sehr dünnen Eis uns bewegen wir hatten
bereits nach zwei sieben acht die
älteren von uns erinnern sich noch und
die noch nicht so alt sind dass Sie sich
noch erinnern wissen dass wir damals
eine Wirtschaft zum Finanzkrise haben
also seitdem haben wir das ganze Problem
nur verzögert durch Geld drucken wir
mussten jetzt mit Geld drucken aufhören
in dem Moment wo Inflation reinkam
Inflation wurde durch Corona durch das
der Trennen der Wertschöpfungsketten
befeuert durch den Wirtschaftskrieg den
Trump mit den Chinesen vom Zahn
gebrochen hat und jetzt auch durch den
energiekrieg also wir müssen aufpassen
dass die Notenbanken jetzt nicht allzu
sehr auf die Bremse steigen müssen um
die Inflation einzudämmen weil dann
nämlich das Kartenhaus an der Wall
Street in Frankfurt egal wo
zusammenbricht ich glaube wir haben noch
nicht begriffen dass wir seit
vielen Jahren jetzt Probleme nicht
wirklich gelöst haben nur weiter
geschoben haben das ganze spitzt sich zu
es gibt einige die von der Wirtschaft
sehr viel mehr verstehen als ich die
hier Alarmglocken läuten die ähnlich wie
vor zwei sieben zwei acht auch nicht
gehört wurden also es kann durchaus sein
dass wir eine massive Korrektur haben
auch mit China ist nicht alles
ausgemacht das haben wir ganz außen
vorgelassen ich glaube China spielt hier
auch eine ganz große Rolle auch was die
Ukraine angeht da gibt's jetzt
Friedensangebote und auch wieder
Aufbauhilfen die die Europäer sicher
gerne in Anspruch nehmen wenn die
Amerikaner kein wahres mehr rüber
wachsen lassen sie sagen ja der Geld
haben in Amerika wird ewig offen sein
vielleicht auch deswegen weil man das
eigene Geld drucken kann und es nie
zurückzahlen können wird und auch muss
vielleicht sollten wir als Europäer
ähnlich handeln und uns selber auch mal
in der eigenen Währung in Euro
Verschulden
gerade die These auch gehört was mit
unserer Wirtschaft passieren könnte
Strompreise auf Platz zwei hinter
Burkina Faso wäre das in den USA eine
Situation wo die Menschen auf die Straße
gehen würden ja natürlich also ich meine
diese
kitchentable Politik in USA ist sehr
wichtig und ich gebe Herrn wernold
absolut Recht in seine Einschätzung das
könnte ich alles unterschreiben was euch
hier gerade erzählt hat und ich glaube
wenn man so ein bisschen brain hat dann
hat man diesen Durchblick und ich rede
hier in Deutschland mit vielen Leuten
und die sind alle der Meinung ähm und
ich frage mich nur wer hat diese
Regierung oder die Grünen eigentlich
gewählt das ist für mich nach
unverständlich und übrigens in ihrer
Richtung wissen sie man braucht niemand
zu werden sondern wenn ein Unternehmen
sieht das seine Überlebenschancen sind
besser in einem Land als in dem Land wo
es gerade produziert oder ist dann geht
er in dieses Land und keine subvent
Wettlaufs Amerika Amerika stand mal die
rohikaner ihre Partei stand mal
gegensubventionen also da haben sie
einen Pakt mit dem Teufel jetzt das ist
eine politische Entscheidung für ich bin
noch alt genug dass ich mich noch daran
erinnere dass Amerikaner gegen
Subventionen waren amerikanische
Wirtschaft es geht also auch
Infrastruktur oder andere Projekte und
wissen Sie was in Deutschland ist
sowieso jetzt mittlerweile alles
finanziert aus dem Mittel das ist die
ganze Migration ist aus dem Mittelstadt
des Mittel die die Wohnungsbau soll
jetzt finanziert werden
die Industrie soll jetzt finanziert
werden die Heizkosten in Deutschland
sein alles aus den aus dem Töpfen der
das Staates finanziert da kann ich sagen
herzlichen Glückwunsch es gibt es also
wir kriegen wollen dominikanische
Verhältnisse ehrlich gesagt ich möchte
ganz gerne
weinbergpflichten es sind nicht alleine
Inflation Act also das ist sozusagen
noch die Kaffeebohne auf der Sahne nein
es sind die Energiepreise wir haben
Energiepreise von 3 Euro Cent wir haben
Gaspreise die sind ein Drittel so groß
wie bei uns und das hält ein Unternehmen
auf Dauer nicht aussehen ich müsste ja
gegen denjenigen in Wettbewerb treten
denn nun ein Drittel der Energiekosten
hat
kannst du nicht gewinnen und wenn du
dann auch so blöd bist und so bescheuert
bist wie das ist nicht nur Deutschland
aber vor allen Dingen Deutschland sich
die eigene Automobilindustrie kaputt
machen zu lernen man muss sich mal
vorstellen wir haben eine Stromknappheit
wir wissen wäre Rennen ihn eine
stromnappheit und in dem Moment sagt das
Europäische Parlament und der
europäische Art wir wollen die Benzin
Autos abschaffen was brauchen die denn
ja die brauchen Strom in dieser
Situation setzen wir sozusagen noch eins
drauf in der Verschärfung und im übrigen
kostet es unsere Arbeitsplätze von den
Firmen die die besten Autos der Welt
gebaut haben
ganz klar gesagt es muss ich jetzt was
ändern es muss was passieren sie haben
in Ihrem Buch sind glaube ich 20 Punkte
wie Sie aufgelistet haben dafür haben
wir nicht ganz Zeit aber ich möchte
zumindest wissen welche drei Punkte sind
die dringendsten Punkte was muss jetzt
angepackt werden damit wir dieses dunkle
Szenario dass wir hier gezeichnet haben
eben nicht haben werden in schon
absehbarer Zeit gut die drei Punkte sind
erstens wir brauchen eigenes Erdgas und
wir müssen weg von dieser
Negativbild von Tracking damit man darf
ja nicht vergessen dass die gesamte
deutsche Politik und die Medien auf
Putin reingefallen sind denn der soll 80
Millionen in deutsche Initiativen und
europäischen Initiativen gesteckt haben
damit sie das Fracking Gas schlecht
machen es gab so Filme wo dann aus dem
Wasserhahn das schwarze Wasser es verbot
den richtig gesteuert worden ja und wir
müssen endlich mal sehen dass wir das
entzaubern und hier nicht reinfahren und
das wird selber besser machen das zweite
ist wir haben
eigene gute Kohle und die müssen wir
sauber machen dann bringen wir der Welt
einen unglaublichen Beitrag wir klauen
den anderen nicht mehr das Gas weg
sondern wir machen das aus unserem
eigenen Kohlenstoff und das dritte wir
brauchen natürlich mehr Energieforschung
wir müssen wieder junge Menschen
ermutigen sie nicht irgendwo an die
Straße zu kleben sondern zu lernen zu
leisten und etwas Neues zu entdecken zu
forschen das muss wieder Spaß in
Deutschland machen und das wird alles
mit ihrer SPD gelingen da bin ich noch
nicht so ganz von überzeugt aber ich
arbeite daran auf jeden Fall ganz genau
darauf klar ist es gibt Dinge die kann
man nicht schön reden die wollen wir
auch nicht schön reden und da sind wir
auch schon direkt bei Ihrem Thema das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sagen sie das
hat versagt in der corona-krise damit
wurden Menschen die Freiheit genommen
das ist ihr großes Thema in der
Aufarbeitung muss jetzt richtig viel
passieren welche Folgen das haben muss
ja es ist verführerisch Corona ist
vorbei die corona-pandemie ist vorbei es
ist verführ wir können sagen wir haben
es hinter uns wir vergessen alles und
wir lassen das das ist gefährlich weil
wir da nicht lernen wir lernen dann
nicht was falsch gelaufen ist und wenn
man das jetzt mal sich anguckt
Bundesverfassungsgericht und Justiz
allgemein wenn man sich wenn die Frage
stellt hat die Justiz hat er Rechtsstaat
funktioniert während der corona-krise
dann würde ich ganz klar sagen nein es
ist tatsächlich es ist eine es ist nicht
opportun des Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
kritisieren in Deutschland ich tue es
aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
seine Aufgabe nicht wahrgenommen die
Aufgabe des bundesverfassungsrecht ist
es musste Hüter der Verfassung sein es
muss aufpassen dass es muss aufpassen
dass alle staatlichen Institutionen sich
an die Verfassung halten
das ist auch nicht zum Spaß das hatten
Sinn und Zweck es geht darum die
Freiheit der Bürger zu schützen die
Freiheit vor dem übergriffigen Staat zu
schützen und das hat das
bundesverfassungsrecht nicht gemacht es
gab unzählige es gab unzählige
Verfassungsbeschwerden andere Verfahren
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht den
ganz großen Teil der Beschwerden nach
das bundesverfassungsrecht gar nicht
angenommen
einige Beschwerden die Sie entschieden
haben sie einfach mit floskelhaften
Begründungen einfach abgelehnt und die
große Entscheidung zum zur
bundesnotbremse war eigentlich ein
abnickender Politik von der Regierung
Merkel also das bundesverfassungsrecht
hat nirgendwo eingegriffen wir hatten
Ausgangssperren wir hatten harte
lockdowns werden wochenlange
Schulschließungen zum Beispiel wir
hatten alles möglich wir hatten die
härtesten Eingriffe in Grundrechte die
wir in der ganzen die wir in der ganzen
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik hatten und
das bundesverfassungsrecht macht nichts
das bundesverfassungsrecht sagt ja okay
Stempel drauf war alles in Ordnung das
müssen wir aufarbeiten
sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
sehr von der Politik vereinnahmen lassen
in der Zeit ja ganz eindeutig ganz
eindeutig das hat das
bundesverfassungsrecht hat seine seine
Rolle verpasst die Rolle ist wir müssen
die Politik und die anderen staatlichen
Institutionen kritisch kontrollieren das
haben die nicht gemacht
naja wir müssen jetzt den Staat
unterstützen wir kämpfen gegen die
Pandemie und sonst was und wir müssen
alle zusammenhalten und das machen wir
dann auch indem wir alles abnicken und
das ist eben das hat die die Rolle des
bundesverfahrensrecht hat in der Krise
nicht funktioniert und das ist ein
Problem und da müssen wir darüber reden
was am System was am Justizsystem was am
verfassungsrechtssystem nicht
funktioniert hat was hätte man aus ihrer
sich sofort beispielsweise im Ei
Verfahren stoppen müssen wo sind die
Punkte wo sie sagen da liegt für mich
das Größte versagen wir haben ein paar
Dinge jetzt gerade angesprochen wir
erinnern uns da an Szenen Menschen da
draußen Sport gemacht oder Kinder waren
beim Rodeln die Maske nicht getragen da
gab es Bußgelder was sind die Punkte wo
sie sagen da hätte sofort reagiert
werden müssen das sind genau die Punkte
die Gerichte also nicht nur das
bundesverfassungsrecht sondern auch die
anderen die richtigen unteren Instanzen
die haben sozusagen nur auf einige
Experten gehört die bestimmte
Erkenntnisse vorgetragen haben und dann
haben die gesagt okay vor diesem
Hintergrund es ist ja ansteckend also
wird nicht geradelt es ist sehr es ist
sehr ansteckend also dürfen wir uns im
Park nicht aufhalten wir dürfen nicht
auf der Bank sitzt und Bücher lesen es
gibt es gab hunderte von diesen kleinen
Geschichten hätten die Gerichte einfach
sich genauer anschauen müssen was ist
eigentlich die Erkenntnislage es ist ja
nicht so wie jetzt behauptet wird dass
man damals alles nicht wusste das stimmt
nicht man hat nur manche Erkenntnisse
der Wissenschaft die einem nicht
gefallen haben die nicht zu Mainstream
gepasst haben diese Erkenntnisse hat man
ignoriert und da hätten die Gerichte
gleich von Anfang an das machen müssen
was sie eigentlich immer machen nämlich
kontrollieren hard kontrollieren genau
hinschaut was haben sie gemacht und in
letzter Zeit es ist ja es fängt oben an
es fängt oben an das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
Richtung vorgegeben und die Richtung war
wir nicken alles ab und wir unterstützen
die Regierung bei ihrem Kampf gegen die
schlimme Pandemie damit will ich nicht
die Pandemie kleinreden aber es kann
nicht sein dass die Grundrechte und die
Freiheiten in der Krise nichts mehr
zählen die Verfassung und die Freiheiten
gelten immer auch in der Krise das sind
ihre Konsequenzen welche müssen gezogen
werden man sieht ja jetzt auch in der
Politik der kommende Eingeständnisse da
kommen kommt eine kritische
Auseinandersetzung man hat das Gefühl
die Aufarbeitung ist in kleinen Baby
steps im Gange was welche Forderungen
formulieren Sie konkret was muss
passieren diese diese Aufarbeitung muss
richtig anfangen was wir jetzt sehen ist
mehr oder weniger auch dass das so
Nebelkerze geworfen werden so nach dem
Motto naja es war nicht alles in Ordnung
wir müssen uns viel verzeihen und damit
ist Schluss und jetzt gucken wir in die
Zukunft jetzt gucken wir uns andere
Problem an wir müssen einfach ganz genau
hingucken ganz genau die Fragen stellen
an welcher Stelle ist was schief
gelaufen und wie kriegen wir das hin wie
wie kriegen wir sichergestellt dass die
Justiz in Zukunft wenn es wieder eine
Krise gibt die Freiheit der Bürger
schützt und nicht das macht was ich
jetzt gemacht hat also wenn ich so tief
greifen dass wir sagen sind die Wahl
Entscheidungen zum
bundesverfassungsrecht da denn wirklich
haben sie denen das Niveau wie früher
ich habe ja den Eindruck es werden immer
mehr nur Parteigänger gewählt die
sozusagen politisch
sozusagen mit der Bund mit der
Bundespolitik harmonieren
ich glaube dass ich habe das am
klimaschutzurteil gesehen nicht da war
ja auch ein Vorgang der ist katastrophal
da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht
einfach die Meinung der Bundesregierung
durchgewunken und das liegt natürlich
daran dass früher die Politik sich auch
erlaubt hat
eigene Köpfe freie Köpfe unabhängige
Köpfe zu
Verfassungsrichter zu machen heute habe
ich den Eindruck das ist eine
parteipolitische Veranstaltung
diejenigen die am parteivorsten sind die
kommen ins Bundesverfassung ja und
insgesamt ist es auch glaube ich so
rechtlich gesehen sind die
Verfassungsrecht ja völlig unabhängig
kann oder was aber sie brauchen auch
psychologisch oder sie brauchen auch das
Rückgrat um diese um diese
Unabhängigkeit auch auszuleben es nützt
nichts wenn sie sich selber im Kopf
beschränkt und sagen okay okay ich mache
jetzt was die Regierung und das ist
wahrscheinlich das was sie meinen mit
unabhängigen Köpfen früher und starken
Persönlichkeiten die sagen okay auch in
der Krise fallen wir die Regierung jetzt
mal ins in die in den Armen weil wir
haben die wir haben die Freiheiten im
Kopf und sie haben völlig recht
vielleicht muss man oder muss man das
Verfahren ändern mit dem die Richter und
Richterin am Bundesverfassungsgericht
bestimmt werden warum müssen wir das so
im Hintertürchen im hinterkämmerchen
machen zum Beispiel das ist in Amerika
finde ich persönlich jetzt viel besser
da werden die Richter
drei Tage lang gegrillt vom Parlament
und die werden durchleuchten da weiß man
genau welche Person kommt bei uns ist
das so dann kommt ein Name in die
Öffentlichkeit kein Mensch vorher gehört
wir wissen gar nicht wer das ist und die
Aufarbeitung in den USA man hat den
Eindruck läuft auch schneller voran
Untersuchungsausschuss gibt es dort
bereits haben Sie den Eindruck da tut
sich mehr absolut ich meine das ist
nochmal ein Beispiel es ist diese Hans
gesehen dass bei der Pandemie bei der
corona-krise war die ähm bloß Dates die
eben von den Demokraten erklärt worden
sind da gab es diese
spartanische Maßnahmen die wollte man
überall durchsetzen und bei den
redstaates auch Florida Texas hat man
die Pandemie an der war anders behalten
behandelt es gab es nicht diese absolute
Einschränkungen der Wirtschaft in der in
den Schulen und Aussperrungen Strafen
und so weiter und jetzt hat sich das
bewährt übrigens der Säntis deswegen ist
er im Moment so populär in den USA weil
eben diesen wahnsinnig gemacht hat er
hat war eine der die Meinung vertreten
hat das so gelassen und übrigens der
Trump war auch derjenige der gesagt hat
piano Piano langsam wir werden damit
fertig sein was immer über den Kopf
gekostet hat und das hat den Kopf
gekostet erstens und zweitens eine Woche
nach den Wahlen kam ist der falschen Tag
mit der Impfung aus weil es vorher ist
waren fünf Jahre und so weiter und so
fort gibt's keine Impfung und ähm so
viel auch zu der Manipulation der Wahlen
also das war auch ein ein Faktor den ich
hier nur erwähnen wollte abgesehen von
ihren Freunden aus New York Times
Punkten hier sogar war auch ein Weinberg
mal zu oder
ich kann mich erinnern und Trump wollte
irgendwelche Lösungen spritzen lassen
und ich glaube
was gekostet gefragt er hat gefragt über
das mal zur Seite aber jetzt nicht New
York Times aber die New York Times hat
darüber berichtet und nicht nur die es
gibt einem Mann der heißt Leonard Leo
ganz wichtiger Mann der hat mehr oder
weniger die Richter
vorgefiltert das wurde nicht in den
Herings bestimmt sondern da gibt's
Organisation die heißt Society die wurde
ja vor 20 Jahren gegründet und die
werden ausgesucht bei bestimmten Themen
ob sie eben dafür sind dass es möglichst
wenig Regulierung gibt kann ich mit
leben weniger Steuern ja aber eben auch
in der Abtreibungsfrage da gab es ja ein
abtreibungsurteil im Jahre 73 das ein
sehr liberales Abtreibung
es wird aber öffentlich im Parlament
darüber diskutiert die werden bei uns ja
auch vorgefiltert die die Kandidaten
aber das machen 12 Leute aus dem
Bundestag ja dass dieses vorfiltern ist
ja klar das passiert natürlich
ganz großer Unterschied in der Treppe
soweit werden da werden wir schon
Schritt weiter ja
unterstützen in USA nämlich genau diese
abtreibungsurteil das Gericht hat nur
entschieden ob das ist die Sache des
obersten gerichtetes
nicht verstößt gegen die Verfassung die
Verfassung das ist da haben sie richtig
angesprochen das ist das oberste gut das
die außenrichter
verteidigen wollen und die Reste haben
nur gesagt das war nicht richtig damals
das hat der steht nicht in der
Verfassung das Abtreibung ähm legal ist
sondern das soll die Parlamente
ich finde es die Bundesländer
entscheiden ob es richtig ist oder nicht
ich wollte aber ganz was anderes sagen
wenn ich das vielleicht aber auch wenn
ich bin ja war noch nicht dazu gekommen
dem Punkt Ihre Frage zu beantworten es
geht nämlich darum dass bei solchen
Fragen Organisationen aussuchen der der
Leonard leo hat mit trumpendiel gemacht
wenn du als Präsident nur von dieser
Liste und diese Liste ist bestätigt das
hat mir Leonard leer selber bestätigt
zwei Dutzend Richter wenn du nur von
dieser Liste nimmst hast du die
Unterstützung der christliche Rechnung
ich glaube ich muss einem Republikaner
nicht aber ohne Unterstützung wieder
christliche
Problem
wirklich recht geben wenn das so weiter
geht das unser Bundesverfassungsgericht
eigentlich nur noch das abbildet was den
politischen Mainstream von ihm erwartet
wird dann rüttelt das an den Grundfesten
unseren Demokratie das habe ich mein
Leben lang anders erlebt von allen
anderen von
verfassungspräsidenten da hatte ich
immer das Gefühl der schützt mich dieses
Gericht schützt mich vor den Übergriffen
des Staates ja und das Gefühl haben die
Bürger nicht mehr und das ist ganz ganz
gefährlich ja sicher Punkt
ausgefallen ich habe auf jeden Fall
sagen Sie uns einmal welche Konsequenzen
fordern sie denn jetzt ganz konkret wir
haben das jetzt in der Politik gesehen
wir haben auch viele hier in der Sendung
sitzen die sagen die Aufarbeitung muss
so weit gehen dass auch Politiker mal
abdanken wir haben jetzt neue Szenarien
entworfen wie mehr Transparenz
geschaffen werden kann beispielsweise
was fordern Sie konkret also ich fordere
tatsächlich die Aufarbeitung ich fordere
auch es muss parlamentarisch untersucht
werden zum Beispiel muss auch ein
parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss
geben der der einfach mal klärt was ist
da eigentlich gemacht worden und wir ich
fordere auch dass man tatsächlich auch
das Bundesverfassungsgericht in den
Blick nimmt und überlegt was ist da
eigentlich passiert wir können nicht
sagen na ja das ist so in Deutschland so
ein bisschen das bundesverfassungsrecht
ist heilig das kritisieren wir gar nicht
das geht so nicht und wir müssen
tatsächlich auch eine Ebene tiefer
Graben ähm das ist das was sie gerade
gesagt haben oder was sie gerade gesagt
haben dass man einfach überlegen muss
welche Schrauben müsste man im System
vielleicht verändern zum Beispiel muss
man dafür sorgen dass andere Menschen
Richterinnen und Richter werden zum
Beispiel wie kann man da was machen das
wären so das wären so die Idee es gibt
verschiedene Ebenen auf denen man
arbeiten muss auf jeden Fall noch vieles
zu beleuchten noch vieles zu besprechen
und vielleicht auch noch vieles zu tun
vielen herzlichen Dank an meine Runde
für diese lebhafte Diskussion und ganz
herzlichen Dank natürlich auch an sie
fürs zuschauen hier bei 8:15 Uhr
[Musik]